Today, what I'd like to do
is focus first on desoto.
Uh, and then on the larger question,
you have your informal property back,
Jennifer.
Uh,
and then on the larger question
of what's the point of all this,
what is
the merit of capitalism?
And we know a lot of things that
capitalism isn't really great app.
Uh, and we know that it has, if
you let it run its own course,
it is inclined toward instability
and it is inclined toward stupendous
disruption of the planet.
Uh,
and yet I, for one, am a, uh,
guarded enthusiasm for capitalism.
So the underlying point of it,
a must have something to do with helping
people to have a fuller capacity to
lead their lives.
You might call it a
practical freedom and the,
the subject for today and for next Monday,
uh,
bring that out. That is, uh,
today with Desoto and I'm going to call
and several of you to think about how
you would use 5% of the GDP of a
country to do as much good as possible.
Um, and then on Monday,
uh, the white tiger,
uh, which, uh,
illustrates quite powerfully
that increasing the average,
uh, average income or
wealth in a country, uh,
can be a wonderful thing,
but seen from the very
bottom cannot be so great.
Uh,
and a protagonist in white tiger
is a brilliant articulator,
if you will, of of that problem. Okay. So,
uh,
the photograph in front of you is meant
to call forth desotos idea of Brow
Dell's Bell Jar, uh, and the foreground,
uh, a vast favela, uh,
is all informal property and
because it's informal property,
it is dead capitol.
And the background,
uh,
is not only live capitol
and formal property,
but extremely dense
piling up of live capital.
It is an expression of intense economic,
uh,
activity and presumably for the
most part of great economic success,
desoto on page pages one 61 61 has,
first of all,
he has some type type face there that is
a small enough that I can't read it and
my guess is many of you will struggle
to read it. But at the top of the page,
he has a bridge, uh, showing, uh,
his prescription for the path from dead
capital on the left to live capitol on
the right across the top.
The roadway, if you will,
is the commercial strategy,
the creation of businesses,
uh,
the taking of debt in order
to create new enterprises.
And then the process by which a desoto
and his disciples first map out the
problem,
uh,
and then engage in a political and legal
strategy to create the framework for
formalized property all the
way to the bottom of society.
And then the operational
strategies whereby that has
implemented a neighborhood
at a time of Avella at a time.
MMM.
Desoto is a deadly serious about this,
and it's a practical enterprise.
Uh, I'm going to Peru, uh,
at the end of term to, uh,
sit in on a,
an attempt by a desoto and his fellows
to formalize a set of neighborhoods
around the city.
And I hope to write a business case that
will be used in this course a year from
now on that trip.
Now, uh, if you
take the totality of, of desotos book, uh,
the only thing worse than leaving informal
property informal from his point of
view is force fitting a formalized
system invented in a university,
uh, onto an existing system
of informal property.
And I'd like to,
uh,
talk about that with you for a few
minutes and give you a case, uh,
from my own experience
in an American setting.
Well,
informal property,
these are boundaries in an imaginary
informal property system, uh,
which correspond to the ingrained habits
and customs of the people who own this
property.
And the,
their inclination will be always to
defend it against a change imposed
arbitrarily from outside.
And if you ask a smart professors
at the Yale School of Management,
uh,
what's the most efficient way to
lay out the boundaries of property?
They'll give you something like the red
grid here with right angles and straight
lines and right angles and straight lines
have a brilliant history in American
property law.
Uh,
President Jefferson a laid out a grid
like this on all but the northeast corner
of the u s of longitude and
latitude lines defining,
uh,
sections of 640 acres.
And the whole development of the
American West is actually on,
with the exception of the
mountainous areas. For example,
the Sierra Nevadas would that exception,
the whole country looks like,
uh,
this rectangle rectilinear grid.
And as you fly from coast to coast,
you can see the grid laid out,
uh,
in a perfectly symmetrical way
with center pivot irrigation,
interrupting the grid from time
to time and an occasional river.
Uh,
the better way according to de Soto is
to adapt a formal systems to fit informal
systems.
So to incrementally add the perimeter,
a metes and bounds shown
here and ultimately to can
convert the old boundaries
to new boundaries.
Uh,
the old boundaries being recognized
only by people living within this little
area.
Dot.
New Boundaries being recognized all the
way up to the nation state level and in
theory,
all the way up to the world level.
If people from another country are
engaged in a property transaction.
For example,
if the owner of this land,
uh,
seeks to take debt from a bank in
New York and the property is in Peru,
uh,
the whole world's system is involved in
the formalization and the obligation of
the Peruvian government to honor a
contract with an American bank would come
into play. And so even the,
even at the very lowest level,
the ultimate chain of connections to
the top level of government on a world
scale, uh, is important.
Um,
nearly 20 years ago,
um,
a fellow named Kurt Schmoke,
a Yale class of about 1970,
uh, and sometimes senior fellow
of the Yale Corporation, uh,
was mayor of Baltimore.
And I didn't actually have
him as a student here,
but I was working then on,
uh,
cities that had too much housing
and which I called under a crowded cities.
If you read all the city
planning books from that period,
it's all about how do we handle all this
new population that has to be housed.
And of course,
the real story for a city like
Baltimore was a vast housing surplus.
Uh, anybody come from
Baltimore Wa or, all right,
I'll settle for Washington or
Philadelphia or Wilmington.
What have we got in the back
there? What, what city? Okay.
Can you,
and we've got a mic for him.
Can you give us a,
a,
a feel for what an neighborhood
constructed of row houses looks like?
How it's organized? Well, I can tell you
about Baltimore's. I see it on the train.
It looks just like that all
the houses are boarded up,
all their backyards or trashed and
there's a lot of vacancy and just desolate
wasteland. Okay. It's still a mess, right?
Which means I was not very effective.
Um,
and Mayor Schmoke was not
very effective. The, um,
the difficulty with row houses or what
the economists call an inferior good,
the standard Baltimore
row houses nine feet wide,
the widest are 16 feet wide.
So it's like living in a
railroad car, uh, or in,
if it's a tall one, two or
three real railroad cars
stacked on top of each other.
And by and large, people prefer
ranch houses, which are more more,
which more nearly
approximate a square layout.
And people also don't like,
uh,
living around visible signs of
decay like the ones just describe.
And when I came on the scene,
and this is a very
abstract representation,
but the green dots represent the,
the squares represent property units
and the green dots represent occupied
units.
The yellow dots represent units that
are still standing but condemned.
And the blank units represent areas
where the house has been torn down.
And there, there's no, this, there's
no precision in what I'm doing here,
but it'll show you the difficulty of
trying to change something for the better,
uh, in a, in it, I didn't even
know desotos work at this time.
I was acting on the
same general intuitions,
uh,
that he has,
that we're at the edge of the bell jar,
the slides just in the wrong place.
But the red line is the edge of the
bell jar.
Well,
one solution
to missing properties is
to install waterfalls.
This was done as a joke by
a student at Johns Hopkins.
Uh, it didn't involve in the
actual water or construction.
It's just a photographic joke.
Um,
but another approach and the one that
I advocated is to triage neighborhoods
and to take a neighborhood like this
where you have very few occupied units,
most of what's there standing is condemned
and lots of vacant lots.
And to say,
let's find a way to use the wealth of
people living here to improve conditions
in a more promising adjacent neighborhood.
So
the first thought,
uh,
is that you take down the,
condemned houses in the unworkable area.
Uh,
and at the same time you offer a swaps
where you buy for what it's worth,
which is not a lot.
You buy houses in the unworkable area
from people and part of their payment is
clear title to a similar space in a
more promising and nearby neighborhood.
So there is a,
uh,
you were creating a market here that has
a barter element in it for land and a
small cash payment and a,
uh,
an effort to admit it to facilitate
the financing of replacement housing.
Okay.
Uh,
actually has a slide deck.
And so after the people make those moves,
this is theory.
You get a much denser
occupancy grid in the top
and you get some benefit from that one.
One is that crime generally goes down.
A neighborhood which is mostly vacant
lots is an invitation to criminal activity
and the statistics on
this area in Baltimore,
and it had hundreds of
areas like this one,
the crime statistics are brutal.
Uh,
another fact is that the administration
of public services is wildly
inefficient,
where only a few houses in a neighborhood,
uh,
have trash to take away a where
streets need to be plowed and cleaned,
uh, even when very few
people use them. Uh,
and where police services
are stretched extremely thin.
So the idea is to densify one
area at the expense of another,
uh, and then to demolish, uh,
to demolish and replace the condemned
houses in the stronger neighborhood.
And you've made some progress. Well,
the first thing, the first thing that,
what's the first objection
that comes to mind?
Yeah.
What do you do with this?
This is now vacant area.
What do you do with it?
Anybody got a suggestion?
Sasha? Make it a park. That's good.
Uh, and it could be a park
with a huge lake in it.
Likes are much easier to administer them.
You don't have to mow lakes.
And a crime is relatively scarce on
aquatic crime is so far as I know,
rare.
Um,
or in some points that you
make it a golf course. Uh,
there was a place in Miami where they've
created a zone where they've just,
uh,
it just grows wild.
It's largely bamboo and there's
a 12 foot fence around it.
And the thought is that 50 years from
now somebody will figure out what to do
with it. Um, the,
so that's one problem,
but there's another set of
problems that are even tougher.
And that is that all of these
neighborhoods have leaders
and leaders are not really very generous
about having you take their followers
away, right? People who are say,
Alderman or people who are head of a
neighborhood development board or of a
neighborhood crime watch, they all come
forward and they say, this is madness.
These people live in perfectly
good houses where they are.
And the ultimate effect is to drive the
transaction costs through the ceiling.
The costs of getting the deals made is,
uh,
astronomically high. I mean, it's a, it's,
it's a perfect illustration of why the
Coase theorem is serious because if the
transaction costs are high enough,
even obviously beneficial
to all sides swaps,
uh,
just don't happen.
And De Soto is dealing with environments
in which transaction costs are
extremely high in which the difficulty
of getting things like this done,
uh, are, uh, is just very,
very great so that it's fine for you
and I to read this elegant little book,
but that's very different from actually
accomplishing things on the street so
that this triangular relationship
between imagine an imaginary leaders,
uh,
would become a dominant obstacle to
completion of the task back to coast.
Uh,
the thesis,
as you will remember, is that where
there are clear cut entitlements,
a high degree of transparency
and symmetrical transparency
and low transaction
costs,
efficient swaps are feasible.
And on the surface,
uh,
Desoto is all about clear entitlements,
but he's perfectly aware that without,
uh,
being able to execute economic
transactions, for example,
borrowing against a clear entitlement,
uh,
very little has been accomplished.
And that if a corruption,
for example,
interdicts transparency,
those transactions won't happen.
Or if they do,
they will be the wrong transactions.
So
one way to think about about how to use
desoto practically is to take the three
conditions from,
uh,
this simplified version of the coasts
theorem and put them in a table with
relatively practical, uh,
categories that you can,
you can deal with and then
look for ways in which,
for example, uh, education,
my impact, uh, transparency and so on.
I'm going to, I mean, uh,
what I want to do is proceed much
less formally than this. The charters,
it's kind of,
it's a very rigid framework.
It's not a bad framework,
but it's a rigid one.
Now have some of you thought about how
you'd spend 5% of the GDP of a country
wave if you have,
I've got one too.
Okay.
More w one,
two,
no one in this section three.
No one's fessing up in the front row here.
Over here.
Okay. We're going to, oh, there
we are on the back. All right,
so we're going to do some winging here,
I'm afraid.
That's okay.
And lastly,
will you trade me places?
Um, Yup. There's some truck
now what the exercises to figure out if
we can create large increments in useful
wealth by spending money.
Was it Tom? Is it, what have we got?
So I think it's education.
It's sort of the key to everything else.
Okay. You would put education ahead
of any of all of other things,
all other things. Okay.
Uh, help us understand why,
uh,
because I think having human capital can
increase your investment and everything
else,
but without that you're not going at it.
The people that you need to build roads
or expand property rights or all these
other things.
Okay.
So education a relatively well educated
populace is a necessary condition,
is that what you're
saying? Absolutely. Okay.
Are there any necessary conditions
to a well educated population?
Uh,
well educated teachers.
Okay. So we have to have a
well educated teachers. Do we,
are there any other
things we probably need?
Yes.
Food running, clean water, electricity,
all the infrastructure.
You buy that Tom Sister.
Okay.
So education was expensive to begin with
and now it's looking more expensive.
So we're probably gonna need more than
5% of GDP to get very far with that.
But that's a good thing.
Tall.
The other problem with education is,
is
that unless the costs
of the education for those workers are,
are not extremely high, they're not,
they're not going to go to school. The
kids will end up trying to make as little,
as much money as they can to support
their families. Okay, perfect.
I ended up actually educate,
absolutely
spot on. And then there's
an incident in white tiger,
which is exactly about that,
where the uncle comes and drags the,
our protagonist away from school because
his Labor has been exchanged in a
family deal. Yes. Back.
Let's just put a little lag in the
conversation. So the, the mix get there.
There's also a cultural problem,
like certain societies don't
want females to go to school,
so there's something deeper than just,
you know,
opportunity costs at work there that
must be dealt with in other ways.
Okay. Uh, I, I'm sure you're right. She,
can you give a specific example?
Um, well I was watching a
movie, it was about, um,
it was about like an Indian societies in
which like women are not allowed to go
to school and helped.
Um,
that figure in the movie to leading
hero was actually based on a real life
figure who went into the village and
convinced all these different families to
let their children go to school.
Um,
because it would be better for them
in the long run but like not based on
opportunity costs but basically tried
to change their cultural kind of closed.
Okay. And what, what's behind this
prohibition on educating women? Do Spouse?
Um,
I think it's partly to do with the meals,
so nice to,
so I'll put that on the APP.
I know that in certain families as well,
like the female cannot be more
educated than a male in America.
I certainly believe in.
Yeah.
So I'm,
sometimes a family believes that if
they are females are too educated,
then they won't be able to marry
them off or something like that.
Okay. That's terrific. Right? Yeah. Yes.
You also need infrastructure in place and
laws in an economy place for like what
they're gonna do after they go to school.
So like in Cuba they have fantastic
education but no opportunities for anyone
like after that's finished.
So for education to be effective,
like you also have to invest
in sort of like the next step.
Okay.
So for education to be effective
we have to have a next step.
Is the Cuban example when you know well,
uh, I wouldn't say I
know. Well that scares me.
I don't want you to ask me that question.
I don't know.
Well, can you, I mean
I've got a couple of,
I've been to Cuba a couple of times and
I have a couple of Cuba stories that
good fill in the blank.
But how about you was drying first?
Um, I tried to go to Cuba last
year. I didn't get a visa,
so I don't know it as well as I would.
Um,
they have,
well it has a lot.
I mean it has a lot to do with the
like communist socialist model.
There's just no, there just
aren't any jobs, aren't any.
So like if you're educated as a lawyer,
you just end up being like a
taxi driver no matter what. So
good Thursday,
I have a friend who might met in Havana
who was sort of top five among the
fishery scientist in Cuba,
phd in biology.
And he was,
he kept giving the wrong advice after
the Russians pulled out in the so called
special period.
Uh,
the government wanted to double and double
and double the harvest of shrimp and
there are limits on the ecosystem
and he kept saying you can't do it.
And finally they declared him unemployable
and the effect of that was that he
became a taxi driver
and troubled his income.
It was still a very low income,
but it was trouble when he
was making as a scientist.
Hands over here.
Yes.
Have we got a second mic working here?
Anywhere?
Okay. One of the downsides
of education is brain drain.
You put all your resources
into educating people,
but there are better opportunities in
other countries for them to go work,
make money and stay there.
So if you are going to put education as
your main emphasis to need to have some
sort of incentive within your own
country to have people remain okay. Tom,
do you want to answer that?
Yeah.
So I,
I agree that that's a problem,
but I think it's maybe less of a
problem than it first appears because of
remittances where even in cases of brain
drain where people get well educated,
go to be doctors in America
rather than in India,
there's still going to send
some percentage of that
money home in the form of
remittances,
which can do a lot in itself to prop
up and they copy great toward the back.
So I won't take all the credit for this.
Richard has been convinced me by degrees
as this goes on. Uh, I think that, I mean,
I think you'd rather have 100% of that
income in your country and the wait to
get that would be, uh,
through, for instance, great.
Creating pools of capital in your country
through direct foreign investment and
in the way you would get that is through
investments in infrastructure and
security.
Okay. So now we're, we're,
we have veered a long way from education
when we talk about direct foreign
investment.
Um,
would you put that as a high priority?
Yeah. Higher than education
because I think that that comes,
but I think you need to,
I need to be able to give people jobs and,
and a livelihood before you can
think about educating them. Okay.
What do you think Tom?
So I think you're sort of endorsing the
idea of offering your country up is to
be colonialized won't last.
Right. In saying that, well,
the best thing that we can do to spur
economic growth is to offer herself as an
extractive nation and we'll build the
roads for people to come in and take out
what they need it.
And I don't,
I don't know if that's the solution
for long term economic with it.
That's how I would read
that, uh, interpretation.
Richard,
I think in the long run, in order to
build sustainable growth in your country,
if you're starting off where you
don't have any of this infrastructure,
educational facilities in place,
you have to find some sort
of competitive advantage.
And that the initial standpoint
that's going to be your labor,
that's going to be your resources.
Anything you can offer up that's going
to attract investment to build out the
rest of these different, um, you know,
pillars of what you need in society.
You can't just start off with here's
the school and we're going to educate
people and they're going to keep
all the value within society.
They're going to capitalize on it.
There's not an incentive
based to really do that.
So until you can actually move up the
ladder of competitive advantage and
development of your markets and
education and quality of life,
it's sort of putting the cart
before the horse in my opinion.
Okay. Now, um,
what's fairly obvious in this conversation
is that you've got to try to do more
than one thing at once,
right?
We just say education full,
full stop.
Or if we say foreign direct investment,
full stop,
we're not going to get it done.
And there has to be a complex
spiral of these things.
And this is why the book by Clark that
we read is one persuasive on this point
because it takes one thing at a time
and then says, well that won't do it.
And it's the spiraling of
several things at once.
A show shot effect.
I think the problem goes back to the
question at hand because of the 5% of the
GDP,
you really can't talk a little louder.
I think the problem goes back to the
question at hand because you can't really
do much with 5% of your GDP.
So people are more likely to create this
false dichotomy of options just because
they have limited resources.
Okay. So, but if,
if this were a real exercise and you had
control over 5% of the GDP of Cuba or
Peru or Nigeria,
um,
you, what would you do? You've got the 5%,
what's the first thing
you better figure out?
I think you have to focus on getting
basic resources and developing a basic
structure. So you may have to forfeit
your emphasis on education immediately.
Okay. So, but the,
what I'm driving at is that you would
want to look at what's already happening
in the right way. Right? You would
want it, you'd want to, there are,
if there are 12 conditions
we're worried about,
you'd want to survey and figure out
that there were three or four where you
could ride somebody
else's dollar so to speak,
and then you would figure out some crucial
Shep of others that you would have to
pay your attention to. Does that
sound right? I think that's fair.
I think the problem lies in,
and I'm,
I was focusing on central Asian countries
when you gave us this mini assignment
and the problem comes when you devote
everything to foreign direct investment.
When do you stop?
Like when do you transition back to
meeting off those other criteria that you
laid out in the beginning?
Okay, so, so it sounds like,
it sounds like this a pretty complicated
subject, Richard, I apologize.
Wanted to clarify what we were,
our point was,
which is by attracting foreign investment,
the idea is that it's
not mutually exclusive.
So instead of taking eliminated 5% of
GDP and allocating towards one aspect of
society, if you can signal to
the broader market said, yeah,
you're an attractive investment place.
You've now grown that pool of capital
such that it can be invested through all
the different aspects of what you need
to build society as opposed to cherry
picking one over another. That's the
goal of a tragic multiple investors. So,
so one of,
okay,
so the one thing we're at least clear
about is that there is no secret sauce,
right? There's no one secret sauce
that is going to get this job done.
It's vastly more complex. Now, who did
you have your hand up a moment ago?
I did, but I think it's,
um, it's been a cover. Sure.
Okay. Uh, who's, who will
give us a fresh start
all over again.
I was going to say that what desoto
keeps emphasizing is the importance of
political leadership.
Somebody forgets,
is that in many of these
developing countries,
the political leadership itself is very
corrupt and as long as it's within the
leadership's best interest
to move the society forward.
So I thought that empowering education
will give us better leaders that would
follow desotos ideas of transforming
debt capital last show you and Tom are
playing the same tune more
or less? Yeah, same tune.
It's slightly different
rationale. Yeah. Okay, good.
I was just about to add to that with an
example actually of a Kosovo case that I
had experienced the summer.
Um, when I was in close,
they had a hard time attracting leaders
because most of them had like fled as
refugees and the 99 more,
um,
so the USA ID program had invested in
instead of like this foreign direct
investment project. I mean like
there their projects in that as well.
But it professional studies
course that educates leaders,
particularly in finance and
investments in these sorts of things.
So it's bringing the brain drain back,
whoa.
Like back into the country and
investing in leaders instead of,
and so then once they have an efficient,
like leadership base, they can go out
and like do these things themselves.
Did I just hear you say that MBA education
is the most important thing in the
world?
Would that be nice?
But,
uh,
who would are there?
Why am I doing that?
Who would start us with an
entirely different starting point?
Yes.
Wait for the mic.
Yeah.
I don't know how you'd do
this with 5% of the GDP,
but I think if there were a secret sauce,
it would be efficiency
and low transaction costs.
Is this coming from like my
experience in Latin America,
which like I've worked there and I've
traveled there and I don't even understand
how they do business there ever
because it's so inefficient. Um,
like down to little things like I know
when when on Saturdays they don't have
enough coins, but you can only
pay with coins to ride the bus.
But like there's a shortage of coins.
And so sometimes you just can't like get
on the bus because you like have cash
but you don't have coins. Um,
so like little things like that,
I don't know how you would like,
where you would even begin to invest
to make those things more efficient.
But I think the like foreign directed
investment and the competitive advantage
all flow from that.
Like you're not going to be a good
candidate unless you have like low
transaction costs within that country.
Okay.
So what of what I think I hear you saying
is that you've got to get the coast
there.
I'm working
right and that has something to do
with corruption or a lot to do with
corruption of the government. Yup.
Um, and like the legal system.
Okay, go ahead. Yes.
A couple of things I do here,
so if you're getting 5% of the GDP,
one thing that we should keep in mind
is that we can assume that the economy
will go on forever.
So I have not spent 5% of the GDP in that
way given ERL divided over a number of
years.
The second is that the money that I'd
be getting and not leave a penny in the
hands of the comment,
I would give it to the private sector,
Al Yamaka thousand villages and as the
private sector to use that money in those
thousand villages the next year
based on their performances.
The second allotment that I would get
out of that 5% of the GDP would be again
given to the private companies
who have performed well,
now I'll leave it up to them.
How do they want to develop the villages?
That can be a holistic development.
It can be a incomplete development,
it can be corrupt development.
But the second year three sources
would be only going on the basis of the
quality of the development.
Okay.
So what you want to do is put as much
rocket fuel as you can in the rockets that
are already moving.
Exactly.
But it makes sure that the rockets,
the next day, the rockets move based
on the performance of the rockets.
And if you were a public official, would,
would there be some problem about that?
You imagine a lot of problems,
right?
Because I mean,
the natural tendency is to redistribute
from the functioning rackets to the
nonfunctioning rockets.
Right?
And the action we saw at 20 times
earlier in term about how a defining
characteristic of capitalism is
that failing enterprise with spam.
Right? And that's one of the ways
capitalism becomes a learning machine.
So,
um,
you are a cruel,
a cruel but wise man.
Yes.
In many ways.
This is,
I guess the sort of the
opposite of the last comment,
but you could also see some validity to
the point of using that money to try to,
um, improve government and capacity
and their sounds because as we've been
discussing,
the government is really a strong point
for creating the stability needed for
investment in other,
in other parts of the economy.
So if there was some way to say like,
use,
use the money to increase the reach of
the government into more rural regions of
the country or to create secure borders,
things like that.
Um,
that I think that that could
have a potentially positive
effect and it's a sort
of a more direct,
um,
direct and centralized use of it.
So it might be a little bit easier.
Obviously you run into problems with
corruption in government and that's minor,
but
so that's a very plausible thought,
right? Where you have a weak state,
which doesn't have the ability,
ability to actually enforce the law,
uh,
or to carry out policy and an
effective way, say in rural areas,
think of western China or large chunks
of Afghanistan or nearly all of Somalia,
uh,
strengthening the state.
If you've got the right incentives for
the people who benefit directly from the
increment of power,
you've got to have the right people
there with the right incentives.
And if you have the wrong
people with the wrong incentive,
you're actually gonna make things worse.
Okay.
Tall.
I sort of have two different,
very different ideas.
One that's sort of bottom up and when
that sort of top down from two different
parts of the world, the first
one that sort of bottom up, uh,
would build on the work of
sort of micro finance. Um,
especially in India and countries like
that where we've seen that if you give
entrepreneurs, even at the
village, some basic capital,
they can even based on their input
that they're dead capital sort of,
they can turn it into live
capitol, um, themselves, um,
especially women.
Um,
and if you focus on that you can maybe
build up sort of a local economy that's
sustainable in its own right and not just,
um,
sort of at the whim of
FDI at the same time.
Um, to use a part of the world that I'm
a little more familiar with. Um, Israel,
my parents are from Israel and spent
a good deal of time. There used to be,
it was built up. I'm going to keep
boot system of socialist system,
um,
and had many of the same problems of
the former communist nations almost at
first and then transitioned
into a much more capitalist,
a market oriented economy,
one that is arguably quite strong.
And part of the way that was accomplished
was as much as it pains me to say
through state sponsored enterprise
as much in the way that China, um,
accomplished it.
Um,
and in the sort of building up of basic
utilities and infrastructure and the
companies that serve the people's
needs for those and then sort of spread
outwards,
eventually turning that informal sort
of communal property into individual
property and live capital.
Okay, let's stop and take
stock here for a minute,
right? We've heard, um,
a dozen or 15 points of view,
uh,
every single one of them intelligent,
oh and no single one of them.
Any major fraction of an answer.
So there is some pattern
of webbing together,
different strategies
and of costume fitting,
uh,
those strategies to the circumstance of
actual countries and actual cultures and
actual governmental systems and
actual infrastructure systems.
We've said very little so far today
about infrastructure and arguably,
uh,
trains.
Planes harbored all lap
a should be at important,
at least late stage and very possibly
middle stage element in our strategy.
Uh, next time, uh,
where our text is the white tiger and I
would like to be able to call on you to
bring forth the anecdotes from white
tiger because we're going to use it as
follows.
The circumstances described in this
brilliant novel are almost invariably
circumstances that are
destructive of wealth formation.
And so think about the search,
the events,
which happened the book,
and then in class we're going to flip
them on their heads, so to speak,
and talk about what might be beneficial.
Uh,
to the protagonist and more generally to
a village in India and a village Indian
Indians who come in the
language of the book,
out of the darkness into the cities.
Uh,
and I'll show you a short film
clip of a company called Selco,
which is in the business of making off
grid electric lighting for village in
India. Uh, and then
before the end of term,
you'll see a full business case about
this company. It's a for profit company,
uh, and it depends on
micro finance to sell, uh,
lighting.
There are many parts of India where there
just isn't any artificial light. And,
uh, uh, it's, uh, quite,
quite inspiring and interesting case.
So I'll see you on Monday.
And if you haven't yet read
every last page of white tiger,
do it over the weekend.